Winchester or Winchester the house the
ghosts built or Winchester the Mystery
House whatever this movie is called
where you live I just saw it and
extracted by the spirit brothers who
made undead Daybreakers predestination
and most recently jigsaw I actually
really enjoyed predestination it's
probably their best film Daybreakers is
a lot of fun to jigsaw that was the
eighth Saw movie and here we follow
Jason Clarke as a doctor in 1906 he's
been sent to the Winchester mansion to
investigate whether or not Helen Mirren
Sarah Winchester herself is crazy
because she claims that the ghosts of
the people murdered with the Winchester
rifle that her family was integral in
the development of our haunting this
mansion so he gets to the mansion and of
course weird things happen lots of
sounds at night and things pop out at
him and there's odd voices and strange
sights and it's a horror movie what'd
you expect I really like horror films I
get excited about horror films you guys
know this this one did not do it for me
I wanted to really like this movie I was
intrigued by the fact that the Spirit
Brothers took this project because in
the past they've made films with a
unique vision with stories that showed a
lot of potential less compelling
filmmakers but with this film and most
recently with jigsaw they're on
autopilot it seems this is basically
your run-of-the-mill cliched horror film
tons of jump scares almost every scare
relies on a jolt of music or something
popping out at you and they're always
very predictable someone will look in a
mirror move the mirror multiple times
and every time they move the mirror left
or right you think well now it's gonna
Oh didn't pop out okay well it's gonna
pop out next time oh it didn't pop out
it well it's gonna pop out oh there it
is which was disappointing coming from
directors who have shown themselves to
be way more innovative in the past and
have made more creative films Helen
Mirren typically is very good and she is
good here she doesn't look down on the
material she's giving it her all
although her performance feels like a
shining diamond in the rough kind of
where you have to wade through this
mediocre stuff you've seen a million
times to get to her work especially
since it takes a while to even introduce
her
character but beyond the jump scares and
all of the horror cliches we've all
become so accustomed to my biggest issue
at this film is its lead character Jason
Clark is a good actor but his character
is so bland and dull
he seems like just like a guy that's
there who's had a bit of a traumatic
past as pretty much all characters do in
horror films there's always something
they can cut back to but the film keeps
it a secret for so long
that it makes it difficult to connect
with him early on
sometimes films can get away with that
look at John wick for instance within
the first 10 minutes of John wick you
know about his wife his past and
virtually everything about him
so that when he starts murdering people
left and right you actually have some
empathy for what he's doing and within
the first 10 minutes you know all of
that it takes so long to uncover the
truth of Jason Clark's character that by
the time you do I've checked out from
being invested by him and so since the
film relies on our motivation for him to
care for him or to appreciate what he's
trying to do it makes it hard because
his character is presented in such an
unlikable way from the very beginning he
has a terrible introduction one of the
worst character introductions I've seen
in a long time you instantly don't like
this guy he instantly seems like a pig
and so it's kind of tough to latch onto
his character when you have a horror
film like this with so much potential
because it's based off of actual events
there is a real winchester mansion a lot
of people think it's haunted the
storyline and the various like mini
documentaries you can watch on the
Winchester mansion if you actually
research the real cases which a lot of
you guys know I like paranormal I
like looking into weird hauntings and
aliens and all kinds of strange stories
like that that kind of stuff fascinates
me and so I was intrigued by this movie
there were there was potential but it
just comes off like your average
run-of-the-mill horror film I hate to
say this I might have actually liked a
fake esque documentary of the Winchester
mansion more than a drama about it which
is hard to for me to come to terms with
I just said that but that's how I feel
right now after seeing this movie
because really beyond the performances
and the production design and the fact
that the movie
does look good there's really not that
much to like here I'm gonna give
Winchester a d-plus this is the type of
horror film that's coming out in
February I was expecting to see in
January but actually last January was
maybe the best January I've ever
experienced there was not a single awful
movie there was some mediocre and
disappointing movies but I didn't
experience a single film that will be on
my worst of the Year list I was like the
best January ever I guess this year it's
it's flippin February is gonna be
January uh I also I just want to say
this is like my new favorite shirt it's
like amazing I love it and I'm sure
since many of you would like to know
where I bought it it was one of those
one day only shirt sites so it's it's
gone unless there's like you know
somebody copied the design and it's
online somewhere so unfortunately also I
got a new tattoo which is healing major
Motoko Kusanagi from ghost in the shell'
by B Hendricks collective tattoos in
Stowe amazing artist guys thank you so
much as always for watching more reviews
coming very soon you guys did vote on
Twitter for February's pre-1970s review
and the winner was the good the bad and
the ugly so I'm gonna be reviewing that
very soon look forward to that guys
you're the best
there's always thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]